[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of top five skym mods of the
week I'm Cam and I'm joined by Seb hey
Seb you were just like I've got this
really exciting intro I'm going to go
with nothing you've ever heard before
it's too risky because otherwise that's
when I forget you when I try new things
Seb that's why I never try I've got one
for you welcome back to England cam
thanks Seb where have you been and Seb
was it Skyrim like it was actually just
with more volcanoes more volcano you
know what it didn't have though what
didn't have any Kevin vanord or any mods
so let's get straight to that time for
mod number
one okay Seb Ford welcome to mod number
one and the desktop of our PC I love so
exciting that's because our first mod
today is called intro replacer Game of
Thrones video theme now Seb you want
just before I play it do you want to uh
explain a little bit about what we're
about to see so uh this changes the way
that Skyrim boots up very very simply
and it's done so by a video that
somebody made uh a guy called Brady Wald
made a fantastic Skyrim Cross Game of
Thrones video uh recommended by the way
by Brandon gak and um it's going to do
something along these lines takes a
little bit longer to boot up than usual
o here we go I recognize that theme
June white
run this pretty
[Music]
great
ni wow that was really that was really
great that's pretty good huh yeah so um
I'm not sure I'd want to watch it every
time it's like when I watch Game of
Thrones I I always I I actually I do
always watch it every time in Game of
Thrones actually but with Sky maybe I
want to just get to the action well I
suppose it depends how regularly you
play Skyrim but um true yeah as a as an
intro video it's brilliant by the way
that video took the guy um two years to
make not because it was overly complex I
think he just started it off as like a
pet project and then before he knew it
he was like oh I'm getting well into
this um and yeah it's pretty decent
pretty decent very good job all right
let's get on to our next
mod all right so welcome to mod number
two and back into Skyrim as well here we
are at Half Moon Mill my favorite place
actually a few chickens accessorize it
you know just to dangerous up the place
a little everything you need but we are
not here for the chickens believe it or
not no we are here for mod number two
which is Sky radio by Creator super
nasty pants I'm sure we have used his
mods before or her mods so Sky radio is
very simple it adds a radio to
Skyrim in doing so it allows you to
include all of your own music amazing
Skyrim um and it includes being to sort
of change the music into a format that
Skyrim understands but anything that you
have an MP3 or wave format you can put
in the game and here it is it's dmer
radio that's the one uh you can place it
down uh or you can simply use it all
right should we turn it on so cam I've
added a couple of different tunes that
Kevin might like all royaltyfree you
know just put that out there here we
go ah I know this one well oh you do and
if it's uh if it's something that you
don't like you can always turn it off
turn it back on again and you get a
different tune but you know uh Kevin
might sort of like feel a bit pumped you
know maybe he wants to go for a a run or
you know just some exercise he wants to
go hunting and he to get in the mood
he's like needs some sort of like wub
dubs oh wow activate activate juk box
tune
in oh I know this one as well get a get
angry Rock here this is a good one to
fight to toggle play on enteron I guess
maybe like if you put it in a home that
like as you walk in oh that's awesome
that's a really cool idea why are
they're not attacking me I don't because
they're like I they just won't fight
unless it's to a theme CH oh okay okay
well let's let's sort that right right
now so this one we can fight to though
here we go
yeah oh that's the kill music If Ever I
heard it bring it on guys bring it on
woo see now they're angry here he goes
there it is oh
god oh lovely
timing oh Seb we find the perfect
killing CH it
is Kevin calmly dismembered all of the
bandits
I i' like to think that this is what
plays in Kevin's head whenever he's in
combat he's like he's just on the
exterior it's all aggression but on the
inside it's perfect calm yeah
[Music]
wow need something
perfect finish gorgeous
[Music]
work okay time for mod number three
which this week's Seb is training
dummies provide XP M I wonder what this
does no idea but we're here at the yaser
home of the Companions obv and we we are
here to test this one out basically so
it works with uh melee weapons okay so
you we we need we're going to need to
hack away at this for quite a while CU I
mean Kevin Kevin's a pretty strong dude
um and you can use your bow and arrow as
well now as you'll notice it's you can't
cheat it too easy with bow and arrow
like say I try to cheat from here missed
oh there you go Target too close to
experience gain yeah argue with that
you're not learning anything Robinson
now I've already whacked the base XP up
as much as possible just to try and you
can vary it as well I guess and you've
got modifiers there you go warn if Too
Close enable distance minimum so minimum
distance to Target is 500 units we're
not sure what the the unit is
necessarily so that's great and you can
have it enable it for magic as well
magic and set Power bashing to uh yeah
teach your block that's quite clever I
like the like I like the principle of it
because it sort of makes them less
completely redundant and pointless
before they were just an aesthetic thing
you know they they gave you no benefit
yeah I don't know if you would
necessarily want to train against a
dummy but you could theoretically do
that to just pop you over the edge yeah
uh if you were that close to leveling up
again you know you wish to hunt me I
don't run away I'm training woman oh
that's why I should be shooting my B AR
that so check got this crack shot
yeah yeah oh you hit the target oh there
we go aha you see that said twoand to 29
good chop and we leveled up our two
handed chop
more power attacks i' I've given an
extra multiplier oh I think I got a
point for that one there yeah up again
wow yeah well we have we have set at
like maximum gaming ability so this is
now better than Dam these are some
serious gains yeah yeah these are better
than fighting real people these dummies
are really good at teaching you yeah
don't even waste your time going to the
gym and lifting all we need to do is
hack it a like an old burlap sack
stuffed with hay major gains fine Work
Kevin you you can take the rest of they
off okay time for mod number four which
this week's s is Skyrim landscape
overhaul now you might notice it in
action already we are in the tundra
White Run and there's just a hell of a
lot more big boulders yeah now that's
not the whole mod explain the whole mod
Seb so this mod comes off the back of
trying to make the world feel a bit more
realistic and filled out you know
fleshed out a little bit more so the mod
creat has added all these boulders to
make the tundra around here feel a bit
more harsh and cold and uninviting Rocky
yeah just Rocky and brutal um around
just all around this place you're going
to start finding these kind of um rock
formations that he describes as a little
bit like Stonehenge uh to give it like
an old Nord sort of ancient Vibe they've
been there from the dawn of time so here
also or maybe since today when we
install the mods one of those two so
here in Riverwood for example we've got
all of these new fallen tree stumps and
um I guess I'm I'm guessing it's maybe
like for the upkeep of the town that
maybe they need the extra wood and even
just been building it I mean I don't
know I mean some of these could be a lot
older ancient old trees it just gives
the impression that you know there is
civilization nearby and they have had an
effect an impact on on the landscape and
on on the trees here in particular and
so as you come into uh places that are
snow
just as you start the approach it gives
you a bit more of a hint that you're
getting into the colder territory by you
start to get like deposits of snow as
you approach these big sort of drifts
that have ambled into the the warmer
Parts it's nice it's less of a like an
Abrupt change from Tundra to snow it's
like it does it does do it really fast
more broken ice and detail around the
coastal areas there's stuff in the reach
uh hgar halfar sometimes you know we we
include a lot of dumb mods that are
funny but it's really good also to
include immersive ones too like I think
this one is new cuz I can see the edge
of what looks like a texture there yeah
so I think that but you know from afar
it looks pretty great it just get gives
a bit more um I don't know variety to
the snow it is texture like you say it's
it just sort of fleshes it out makes it
lumpy and and you know a bit more rugged
and there's one thing I love s it's
lumpy snow oh yeah the best
kind okay and time for the final mod of
today set which is of course our user
voted mod and the winner this week was
the Oblivion realm Siri the Gate of
solitude Seb I hope you're ready to go
back to Oblivion oh oh I'm ready you
where are you going I'm going I'm going
up this way there the the road's there
oh yeah i' like to take the rift toop
way for some reason whoa Sab what
started the Gate of solitude yep oh God
it's AR with that it's right in front of
me oh God
Dora
kill these guys have hearts that I can
take them yeah nice I remember these
guys I remember that that sound voice
yeah oh sing back in Oblivion where are
you wor oh it's a guard that's a guard
oh this is what happens quick into the
Gat into the Gat jees it and we're back
in Oblivion man it's it's dark in here
it is real dark yeah I love the guards
followed you in to kill you the guards
Jesus man this this Dora and the
Solitude guards have not got their
priorities in not one bit I want to get
inside the tower I think it's probably
up here all right this looks familiar
yeah this looks
great except for Kevin vanord who always
escapes well he never runs so I guess he
doesn't really Escape that looks invite
what what was that what just happened
what just happened what is going on oh
this is very
familiar isn't this usually where
there's a p of spikes on the floor I
feel like oh man I think I don't know
what we did there but my God he's dead
should we take his batx yeah so we've
turned the em off now Seb and you can
see the uh the darkness is less of an
issue climb the tower it's more purple
than I remember
hello now this looks like a a lovely
room to be in yeah only the best things
happening here who are you nice guy huh
yep better without his head he wants to
Feast on my heart is he coming on to me
do you think I think so
yeah he's saying the words that Kevin
you know resonates with yeah who what
what
what oh what just happened what just
happened and here we are oh this is
awesome Seb there's only one way we can
clear this room you know what it is
what's that chickens let do it do it all
right go chickens
go who oh well there's still some some
of them are still alive you what pretty
strong guys yeah nothing a few more
chickens can't handle yeah they took
down quite a few but this there's still
some more to be killed 50 chcken
go wow now if you survive that then
Kevin will be impressed and he'll be
glad to behead you look at that that's
menacing
Yep they're still they're still going
how many more have we
got wow wow purple if I've learned one
thing there's always more chickens
always more chickens oh oh it's so quiet
and peace in the realm of Oblivion
Carnage W that guy's dis having a disco
dance yeah he's just gring out oh he's
break dancing he's having a wonderful
time we certainly did it killed them all
all this left to do is to high five the
weird Oblivion hands high five Pals high
five sweet high five bro let's do
questions word what's the first one Greg
Cate is the first one he says hi Seb
have you got any advice on what computer
to get for running Skyrim and DayZ on
and a well I think Skyrim's going to be
the limiting factor there so what's your
thoughts pal well it just so happens we
have the perfect solution for you um we
do don't we yeah uh a little while ago
Mark and our American colleague Peter
Peter Brown oh yeah they both made two
separate videos about creating a PC one
Intel based one AMD based for the same
cost as an Xbox one uh both of which are
super powerful you know they'll they'll
run Titanfall yeah they'll run Titan 4
better than an Xbox One or a PS4 would
so depending on whether you want to go
AMD or Intel
uh there's a great great setup for both
the links are both on screen now we'll
put them in the description if you're
watching on YouTube go and watch them
both and that'll give you everything you
need to know in terms of components if
you're going to build one and the next
question said was from the gamer 507 on
YouTube and they asked basically what
was the name of the mod that gives us
the beautiful hd water and also what em
do we use ah so I'm right thinking the
water one is pure Waters it's absolutely
pure Waters Lovely One the en is our new
favorite em Saron sun and it gives just
I don't know it's reprocessed or
intensive but the results are great now
you might have noticed that we actually
we play um when we record the show we do
kind of Tinker with siren some slightly
and we remove the the depth field yeah
it's real heavy it will actually like
half our frame rate it really does which
makes for unless good viewing experience
for you guys so that's why we do it we
do this for you good question though all
right pure Waters SAR and Sun y the next
one the next we asked we asked last week
what the deal was the Obama face from C
and Seb and we said what so if you you
haven't seen the show it was um the
what's it what was the mod called again
um uh the crimes against nature that was
the one and we had this like chairface
guy but it was said it was Obama um not
being American we must have missed the
event but you guys all told us you all
told us that Clint Eastwood did this
speech for the last election in America
because he was supporting Mitt Romney
and I guess as kind of like an
anti-obama thing he had a conversation
with a chair he pretended was Obama yes
yeah all right so that went little over
our heads but uh thank you for clearing
that one up CU we a little confused our
American politics knowledge is good but
not great apparently and lastly we also
found out that May the 4th not not just
sorry I totally jumped in in you there
not just Star Wars Day Seb it's not it's
apparently happy International respect
for chicken day thank you Amy Estep for
letting us know on Twitter and we both
retweeted I think your lovely photograph
which you can see on screen screen
screen even that's a that's a real word
yeah it's on there right now um so yeah
I hope you all celebrated that if you
saw the tweet I know I did I spent I had
a minute silence for all the chickens
that Kevin has killed oh right no I ate
chicken oh you ate chicken I ate chicken
to the ruin and I did it with such
respect such respect respect respecting
every morsel yeah sort of like you know
said some words to it before I consumed
it dearest chicken I'm going to eat you
now wonderful okay Seb let's get on with
the the final part of the show which is
of course always the mod vote Yes what
do we have in the veter today we have
three more mods that you have suggested
to us either on YouTube or Twitter and
the first one is Cold Harbor great
swword uh it's got a bit of some
inscription stuff some purple stuff
looks quite interesting okay up second
we have dragon bone Ebon steel armor
steel if you like to mash together your
your natural and your unnatural armors
all I do oh yes and then we got the YY
anim replacer Miss dick Knights and it
looks to me like this is going to add
some new animations if you are rolling
one-handed weapon and one-handed magic
together looks pretty interesting
excellent well guys let us know which
one you want the best way to do that in
fact the only way to do that is to go to
tinyurl.com
Blog cast your vote and Kevin shall do
your bidding basically and he doesn't he
doesn't do the bidding of much like
we'll do your bidding you Kevin just
does what he wants yeah that's very true
in fact he'll be quite angry at me for
even suggesting he might do anyone
bidding other than his own he's always
angry yeah so um if you want to get in
touch with us to suggest mods for next
week's Vote or next week's show or even
just tell Seb that his hair looks great
that happens quite a lot then the best
way to do that is to get in touch with
me at cam fras Rob or yeah and I'll I'll
pass the message on to se thanks buddy
or you can tell St directly I guess at
ready SE go he doesn't really like he
likes them to come through me first it
makes them feel better I receive them
better that way yeah yeah thank you um
and of course you can use our hashtag
which is G s Skyrim abolutely Seb it's
been a pleasure as always I really
enjoyed going back to Oblivion even if
it was initially very dark and then once
we turn the off real hard and real
purple but you know that's just like
Memories aren't necessarily true to life
and sometimes Nostalgia doesn't quite
deliver but I enjoyed it nonetheless
good okay but we'll be back with fresh
mods and fresh discussion I guess fresh
question maybe a fresh face maybe who
knows we'll see you next week for more
top five scar mods of the
[Music]
week